good afternoon
i'm really really happy to be able to
present the j programming language to
you
unlike other speakers today
i haven't created this program i haven't
thought it up i haven't
made it work in the machine and i
certainly respect
the the people who are making their own
languages
the two people who are most responsible
for
the jay being part of our world
are roger hui and kenneth iverson
roger hui is the implementer he's
programmed the
interpreter which allows us to run j and
also contributed design
ideas across the years
kenneth iverson is the
primary designer for the language
going back to his early life
dr iverson died in 2005.
jay just lights me up i love this
language and i have more fun working
with it than
any other language that i've gotten
into the meat of so far so i've got to
just get into some code and try to lead
you through it let's see i could do
hello world or i could do factorial or i
could do
a cellular automaton or i know i'll do
subtraction
that'll do it i happen to be one of
those people who does think that
code is mathematics on a blackboard
so if we have this
and we were to take
away that then we'd have this
our original has a flaw
so if we derive the flaw and subtract it
from the original
we'll have this and you can do this in
the programming language of your choice
but for the moment let's look at how
it's done in j
this is the code that accomplishes this
and a bit more now in
approaching and this is all of it
in approaching j code it's often helpful
to just
go to the end of the line so the bottom
line here
is where this subtraction comes down to
it
i'll zoom in on the expression
where we have the shadow which we're
calling w here
and we're subtracting it from the
cropped reduced image that we've
prepared
for that that's the bottom line or end
of the
calculation everything else is prologue
so to speak
the first couple lines are
just conventional loading libraries from
from disc what we're looking at here is
a console record
the indentation of three characters is
the j console's
prompt and in um most of the time in the
interactive
approach that jay
favors you enter a sentence and you get
a result back enter another sentence and
get a result
this is a bit unusual we have a result
here and we have a result there
but most of the time we're not seeing
anything back
in this particular instance now the next
three lines
we're setting up a grayscale viewer this
is so we can get that feedback that
interactive
involvement that is important to most j
programmers
again starting at the bottom view wh
that definition is really what this is
all about
we're doing that in terms of glwh which
we've defined here in
vugrey which we defined here and those
are defined in terms of the libraries
that we brought in
the point of making view wh is so that
we can do view wh
of each of the various images and those
produce
windows that pop up and show the
pictures like we were just looked at
so that's just a convenience for the
person who's at the console
the actual computation is what's
showing up here in red this is all we
actually are needing
to do that subtraction
the first line is
drawing a the data from disk
of that original image and converting it
to
grayscale image and then calling that m
we will use that twice we'll use that to
create the
the left image which is our reduced
prepared image for the
for w to be subtracted from and we use
it again
to derive the shadow so
the interesting part starts really here
let's make that big enough
to read it may be big enough to read but
it may be
not enough for you to read it
i can make it bigger but i don't think
it'd help
so what's happening here is an averaging
the blue is
average we'll talk about that later and
the
magenta backslash
is the moving part so we apply this
average across
m which is actually the
the right parameter to this
verb verb is a special term i'm going to
be using a
the peculiar j terminology such as nouns
verbs
trains and forks and you'll just have to
keep up with me or not so
what we're doing here is averaging
across the
image that we've uh made a grayscale
we're going to average this five pixels
at a time
and we're going to average it this
underscore means that
we're going to be doing uh
non-overlapping windows so every five
pixels
we take an average of those grayscale
levels
we go clear across the um
the noun or the input in that manner
and then we do transpose which i've made
blue here transpose flips
the axes and then we apply exactly the
same thing again
and apply transpose again the result has
the original
orientation so that's
our source image from which we're going
to subtract the
shadow let's prepare the shadow
in the next three lines the definite
definition of s of z and w
you might notice there's a sense of
duplication here
and code duplication is often
derided or sought to be avoided
but in the case like this i think it's
actually valuable and i'm going to try
to
give you x-ray vision into as if you
were able to read jay
and and this is the best i can do on
that it looks a little bit like
a an ide but i would not use this
particular coloration for an ide
but the
the yellow or green
parenthesis with the backslash is a
pattern that's produced throughout this
and we have
that moving pattern of applying a a verb
then transposing applying it again and
transposing back
in all three of the long lines here
so in the creation of the shadow
we're going um
by uh tens instead of by fives
again we're doing it with uh
non-overlapping windowing and we're
picking out the greatest of the values
among those 10 pixels
transposing applying that along the
other dimension
and transposing back because we've
uh done that reduction by five
by ten instead of by five it's twice as
reduced as the original
so if we do make it twice as big
on one dimension and twice as big on the
other then we restore it to the same
size
now we want to smooth this out so we're
going to apply
averaging again across our
result this time we're going eight
pixels at a time
and we're not going in a windowing
fashion
we're going in a smooth thing so we get
eight pixels then we move one
pixel over and we average those eight
and we do that across
again both dimensions now the result of
that is not quite a perfect fit
for the other picture
so we take the the shape
of our shadow as our guide and use that
shape to crop
the original at which point we are
able and ready to subtract one
from the other i think that's pretty
cool
one of the big things to take away from
this is that in
j our data which we call nouns
is by nature a collection
scalars are an exception an edge case
that's treated as just part of this
general idea that we are going to have
everything be a collection and anything
we do
with data will be applied across
the entirety and that's why we're able
to
skip having a detailed
specification of a loop in fact we're
even skipping saying
we're mapping the mapping is there but
it's implied in the
the very functions or verbs as as they
are called
this language is not at all new its
heritage really is of roughly the same
age
as lisp
and in
one of its really special qualities is
that vocabulary
which simon payton jones appreciates
here
and each of the um the primary
uh verbs that we see in this are
examples
uh of what he calls array operations
it started literally on a chalkboard so
if it seems old school
it really was this was in harvard uh in
howard aiken's computer science
curriculum
[Music]
and in that period ken iverson who
started
uh this had to solve the problem just
talking about and teaching and
understanding
computation and the mathematical symbols
that were available
just weren't cutting it so he was
innovating
in that process he wrote a book he
called it a
programming language a reminder that
naming is one of the hard problems
um harvard wasn't so impressed with his
little book
but uh ibm was so he went to
uh aiden falkoff's group at ibm and
one of the things that they produced was
a very
uh important thing this was the first
formal
architecture of a computer system
and again in applying
uh iverson's notation this was done by
hand they couldn't put it into a
computer
this was all being done with pencil and
paper
but it was clear that this could be done
in a computer and within a couple of
years they had
it running and interpreters and were
using it to begin to build products
and within a couple uh years after that
they had it out in commercial release
for their customers this language was
called apl uh drawing off of the name of
the
of the book there are
that was a long time ago a lot has
happened in between the trials
tribulations and triumphs of apo are way
beyond what i can talk about today
but i can say that as nice as it was
iverson had a sense that it could have
been better and if he had known
you know what he knew at the end of
decades of
work on the language he would have done
some things differently
so he undertook to make those
differences
real in what's effectively a new
language
and that's what we're looking at today
that's jay a couple years ago that was
um put into open source under gpl
and that may um give it a
wider audience that will be interested
if not in its its particulars i think
there's a great deal to be found in the
general concepts
that are involved with this let's get
back to some code
now before i waved it average and said
well this is average
we'll just go to that to the point where
you can actually understand that
and we're also going to be moving from
noun phrases to verb phrases
and let me mention that as you for those
of you who decide to look into jay the
point where you can
distinguish between noun phrases and
verb phrases
is going to be a really important
transition
the number one stack overflow problem is
i can't tell my noun phrases for my verb
phrases they don't know how to put it
that way
but that's what they're asking um
so i've
defined a noun here i'm uh naming it my
list
again in the console something that i
put in like a name
will be reported by the
interpreter so the sum of my list
is thirty the tally or count
or length of my list is six
and thirty divided by six is five so
that's the average
the we use the percent sign instead of
uh the apl classical division sign
because
with jay um the decision was
made iverson made the decision to move
to ascii
away from the custom characters that had
distinguished apl for so long
that has advantages and disadvantages
so again the
sum of my list is 30 the tally of my
list is six
and if we do the sum of my list divided
by
the tally of my list of course we get
five
just as if we had the numbers themselves
in there
now this is the cool part we can
factor out this common argument
these two verbs on the outside of
division
are the same so instead of having them
each
be arguments to those respective verbs
we'll make them a single argument to the
entire verb
train so we have
the sum divided by the count
this is our program this is the argument
to our program
and it has the same meaning as the form
above it
we can take that program and give it a
name
and then we can use that name and give
it an argument and it has the same
meaning
as before
this is an example of a verb chain and
it's an example of the most
uh important uh part of it
called a fork which has three pieces
and i'm using a triangle here to
represent a
sense of flow a sense of
dependency here we see how average
first deals with the outer
verbs and then the inner verb receives
the
uh results of those respective ones
this branching and converging pattern is
a natural part of the language and it
comes from simply putting
verbs next to one another with nothing
to indicate the higher order operation
that's actually involved with these
three
functions this diagram
is of the same thing this appears in the
j
reference card which i highly recommend
spending time with if you
are working to learn the language the
um
what we have in practice uh
when we have forks and hooks are just
these adjacencies the
in this case it actually will express
this way
for a fork this way for a hook and this
shows the way they are
in effect connected
the next example
i'm not going to step through to help
you understand as much as i did
with average but the main thing i want
to do is
is help you see the way this scans now
the
meaning of is leap is
plain enough if we think of these four
numbers
in as years and we have the boolean
results of whether or not those are leap
years
in looking at that train of
five verbs we
basically as a j reader need to
work like a parser and see the verbs
from the right
and pick three of them because
that's the most that we get at a time
that gives us our train
and ignore the messiness of the fact
that these
don't look like a verb at all looks like
a noun and here i've got this extra
stuff hanging off to say it's a verb
after all
those details you can pick up as you go
the important part is that
these three verbs come together to form
a single verb
and then that is a component
the rightmost verb for the next train
and the result of that is a flow
which in effect is taking
partially applied values uh constants
the list of three numbers uh
in the um
the the four 100 400
and then the zero to compare whether or
not our
residue when we've divided by
these whether or not we have anything
left over
is defected by that so
this is the kind of flow that i envision
when i see
something like that and the
really key point here is that the verb
trains
are higher order functions that
are identified simply by putting the
verbs next to one another this is part
of how that
radical compression of information
occurs in this language
and the the fact that we get branching
and converging
patterns out of this makes it rather
similar to arrows in haskell
okay one last code walkthrough this time
let's
approach it as though we're writing a
program and we don't already know
we're not encountering something that's
already written
a while back when people had to do a lot
of internationalization
i came to abbreviate it
as i 18n so i'd like to write a verb
which will take the word
internationalization and
output i18n okay well how would i
approach that we know i've got tally or
or
count so i can approach my 18
along those lines i can take the head of
word
and that's w i can take the tail of word
which is d it's a bit different from the
list
the oriented languages
and i can take the head
joined to the tail to get a wd
notice again we're getting this fork as
our
unit of construction
but what i want is a w2d now i can put
that in by hand
of course um or and
i can put it in as a whole i could put
it in in three different parts a w
joined to a two joined to a d that works
but if i put a w joined to a numeric two
join to a d no that's not going to work
i have to make that text
so i will format my two
and when i do i get a two back
so boy is that really a numeric two
or is it a um uh the character two
well we can check that by saying
character two equals
the formatted numeric two and we get
back our boolean one
okay well that's reassuring
so the w
joined to our uh formatted numeric two
joined to the d that's going to be what
we want to to make this verb
the the
formatting thing is is going to be in
the middle but um
we need the number okay
so what will we do to get that number
well we take the length of the thing
and we subtract two uh again this is a
a verb train we actually have three
verbs
adjacent to each other the um the tally
this subtraction and the two which here
is a constant regardless of its input it
returns two
so even though it's getting
internationalization as its input
it returns two and the result
of that entire verb is thus 18.
we can use built-in uh
facilities like data type to check
how when we run that
we're working with integers and if we
apply our format to that then we'll get
literal this is a special form of
a verb train that i'm not going to
detail
but that gives us the middle part that
we were missing before
so if we take the head
join to the middle joined to the tail
that's it
now if we give it say by the way
it ends up like this
and that's pretty ugly so let's spruce
that up
we've got middle and numeronim already
defined
so let's check whether or not it's long
if it's
if the length is greater than 3 then
we'll apply numeronym
and if it's not then we won't so
here long is going to get our
our noun from the outside our parameter
or argument
and if it's greater than three then
that's a one
and the one position in this list of
verbs is here if it's not greater than
three then
that's zero and the that's the
pass-through
argument which has no effect
and uh we'll give that a slightly
different name that i've generated using
that or
at least i could generate it if i wasn't
obvious
so here we go uh with this
there we can now uh apply that to
a variety of words and it will compress
the long ones
and leave the short ones open
the last thing i'd like to show here is
how
the names that we're using are very much
for our convenience
in understanding this um making sense of
it both as we built it
and as we come back to it but we can
also
play interpreter
to see the way this really is
equivalence that the names and the
values of
where the values are these verbs are all
interchangeable we can replace
the numeric in
in this with the actual content
of numeronim and we can replace
long with the actual content of long
and we can replace middle with the
actual content of middle
and now our names are all gone and
you know what this says
for more information on jag
jsoftware.com is really the base place
to go
and there are pointers there to other
parts of the internet that cover
this language thank you very much